how's it going bros my name's feel bad
welcome to amnesia the Dark Descent I
forgot what this is called
it's barrels I'm already really really
see what the journalist says a storm is
coming I need to get town ahead for a
mr. dad
pretty awesome music in the background
let's go to town here's our shopping
alright letting Adam Adam oh God
yeah okay we're gonna buy bread and
stuff in town why not
I know mr. chair I don't know I don't
know anything mr. chair
you're so oblivious it's crazy okay fine
the key
how's that it's my girlfriend
oh really
oh come on I just want to go for
shopping oh this is sheriff share my
pity activated pool
the Unforgiven alright that was pretty
quick intro it's sort of like super calm
using and then all of a sudden I don't
know that's just weird
mm-hmm really what's going on here ah
battles did you do this bounce I [ __ ]
knew it barrels
is the key oh thank you Wow
never had a straightforward mob like
that before you should keep dumbass
alright
that's a very long loading screen making
it feel a really awkward all right we're
outside oh that explains the long load
all right nothing bad can happen here
let's go in this way okay you're
everywhere aren't your bowels of course
oh mylanta
sweet sweet I got a Latin we all have
letters actually you don't only I have
letters why they're boxes please
everywhere why am i singing let's go
here let's go to town and go for
shopping [ __ ] I love shopping let go I
got it damn I love shopping I'm gonna
buy a new dress some new pant what was
that some new panties and a bra not for
me of course I don't worry brush what
was that
is anyone there don't [ __ ] around guys
it's not funny
all right let's keep going
let's keep going in the rain
I just want my new address that's why
I'm doing this ah come on stop doing
that
it's not funny telling you it's not
funny
no it's not it is bad good bad wait
okay this is bad it's not good for
anyone feeling someone is watching me
just I have a hint fiddling with that
all right I'm just gonna go keep keep on
going keep up
no huh huh what what huh
but I don't even know anymore oh okay
uh-huh oh [ __ ]
uh what the [ __ ] I don't what I wasn't
scared okay fine we're inside somehow
okay good good good
nothing bad can happen nothing I get
feeling everything's fine everything is
fine blood no normal that's normal for
me that's standard yeah all right
something bad happening here all right
already could be something really good
like that could be my favorite dish like
oh okay that's not my favorite dish okay
good okay let's read what happened here
that's too much stuff for me to read it
hurt my eyes okay
house key really this is what mo Chou
tower activated Boop
okay huh look okay okay we're good we're
good we're good
we good chat him up hit him okay fine
I'll remember it
hello
uhh
hello Center one there
I just came for their up buh-buh-buh
okay share market jammer okay again
hello
and I'm a liar
ha I just want to just want to get the
heck out of here this place I
[Music]
okay uh yeah I didn't do anything I
swear the Clara
I'm gonna gonna okay
okay good good
[Music]
that wasn't a lot of problem white
shirts I reckon lot white chairs
actually I don't I hate charm Sharon
what are you doing
okay that was very interesting though
stream Li's what is this I need the
Latin madam am I don't care give me the
Latin Adam um let's go I don't need I
need a key
I think we can't I have the house key I
can't use it what what do you want for
me
now come on oh there we go selecting all
right
hey tell them
where did that uh Castilla Oh what's
going on here
Oh aah I just wanted to stop okay what's
going on oh it's gusting I hate them I
hate cockroaches yeah Melba mr. chair
oh come on okay they got
[Music]
really mom I don't even know what's
going on anymore
you never see any malls or just this
sound of no monster it's really weird
maybe here perfect
takes going on here somebody barrels
brown st. barrels I hate everything
except I don't know what I don't know
all right fine I'll just this what are
you doing Oh fine
I just lady that he never shows up
anyway I mean oh go go go okay we're
good we're good we're good we're good
we're good
I never been better in my top five bells
know something ah okay so problem let's
block him block him block him huh mr.
chair mr. chair is you later chair mode
activated poop oh you [ __ ] traitors I
will see you wasn't an oh man oh I don't
even know what to do I need to go back
okay second [ __ ] let's just oh [ __ ] he
okay mr. pop you're gonna save my life
really oh it's an honor Petey it's an
honor to save your life nothing no
problem no problem never had a problem
an entire line except right now
save me miss carpet go okay we can go
all right
that was the Unforgiven down
[Music]
alright thanks for watching guys leave a
like and favorite and subscribe if you
haven't and I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
mr. Sherr we're in big [ __ ] trouble
mr. chair let's get the heck out of here
mr. chair mode activate boop I don't
leave it like this